[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily i
understand you have reached a verdict as
to each defendant
the verdict is in in the death of a mod
arborete trial what decision the jury
came to for the fate of the three
defendants and the death toll rises in
the waukesha holiday parade attack there
are not words to describe the risk that
this defendant presents to our community
we take you inside the courtroom for
daryl brooks first appearance since the
deadly crash plus a lengthy
investigation into andrew cuomo made
public why officials say there is
overwhelming evidence the former
governor engaged in sexual harassment
and later organizers of the deadly
charlottesville rally are held liable on
conspiracy claims how much they now owe
in damages law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian vockmeyer along with co-host
terry austin the verdict is in in the
death of a mod arborete trial after a
weeks-long trial the jury returns a
verdict with less than two days of
deliberation all three defendants are
found guilty in the murder of a mod
arbory
count three felony murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
count three felony murder we the jury
find the defendant greg mcmichael guilty
count three
felony murder
we the jury find the defendant william r
brian guilty
trouser mcmichael was the only defendant
to receive a guilty verdict on all
counts those nine counts include malice
murder four counts of felony murder two
counts of aggravated assault one count
of false imprisonment and one count of
criminal attempt to commit a felony
his father gregory mcmichael was found
guilty on eight counts including four
counts of felony murder two counts of
aggravated assault one count of false
imprisonment and one count of criminal
attempt to commit a felony greg
mcmichael was only found not guilty of
malice murder
william roddy bryan received the least
number of guilty counts with only six he
was found guilty on multiple counts of
felony murder one count of aggravated
assault one count of false imprisonment
and one count of criminal attempt to
commit a felony the jury found brian not
guilty of malice murder count two of
felony murder and count six of
aggravated assault
the judge began reading the verdict of
trousing michael upon the first guilty
verdict aubrey's father rejoiced in the
courtroom
count one malice murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael
i'm guilty to ask that whoever
just made it out first be removed from
the court please
joining us today is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
gene malus murder only for trousering
michael but not the others why do you
think that is
well he's the one who approached uh mr
aubrey and he's the one who pointed the
gun and i actually think this is the
right verdict uh you know travis
mcmichael is definitely guilty of malice
murder oh now that one is a tough one
because you got to prove that he had
mouse the forethought when he got out of
that truck with that gun he wanted to
kill him uh and i didn't think they had
that but uh the jury thought otherwise
his father he uh they basically cut him
a break because he was in the truck just
watching and yelling yeah now terry many
experts believe william roddy brian
would be found guilty of the lesser
charges can you explain what the jury
must have believed he did based on the
verdict those charges and the verdicts
in connection with those charges were
very carefully reviewed by that jury
they didn't find him guilty of the
malice murder so that makes sense but as
far as the felony murder if you think
about it everything was in connection
with the truck the felony murder in
connection with the firearm they said no
but the felony murder in connection with
that truck they said yes false
imprisonment they said yes aggravated
assault they said yes so they actually
looked at the evidence and followed the
evidence and applied the law and came to
the right conclusion i actually think it
might even go beyond that maybe they
were actually listening to kevin goff
because kevin goff's major point as to
his client william roddy brian is that
he didn't know that the gun was going to
be pulled out and when the gun was
pulled out he may not even have the
opportunity to stop it so
maybe
hats off to goff in that situation many
of us thought that he was kind of
bonkers or crazy in some of his
arguments but he ended up getting the
least amount of guilty verdicts or
guilty counts sorry as to his clients
and maybe that argument worked we don't
know until we hear from one of these
jurors down the future thank you both
and in other news malik shabazz's
daughter of famed civil rights leader
malcolm x is found dead in her brooklyn
apartment
the 56-year-old died on monday new york
police say shabazz's daughter found her
unconscious in her brooklyn home right
now the cause of death is pending but
officials say it does not appear to be
suspicious her death comes just four
days after two men convicted in the 1965
assassination of her father were
exonerated in a court hearing aslan
crime daily reported muhammad aziz and
khalil islam were exonerated last
thursday aziz is now 83 years old and
islam died in 2009 at the age of 74.
and after 43 years in prison a judge
rules a wrongfully convicted missouri
man be released back in 1978 kevin
strickland was convicted of three counts
of murder at the age of 19. he received
a 50-year jail sentence without the
possibility of parole for the triple
homicide at the time a witness
inaccurately identified strickland as
the man who committed the crime years
later she said she made a mistake by
identifying him she later made efforts
to free him through the midwest
innocence project now 62 year old
strickland has always maintained his
innocence all charges against him were
dropped this week after the judge ruled
the prosecution had the burden of
proving evidence that undermined the
conviction strickland's time spent
behind bars makes it the longest time
served for a wrongfully convicted man in
missouri history
still ahead on law and crime daily the
findings of a lengthy investigation now
revealed into former new york governor
andrew cuomo's alleged sexual misconduct
but first the man responsible for the
deadly holiday parade crash makes his
first court appearance in waukesha
wisconsin we take you inside the
courtroom after this
[Music]
[Music]
with that bail it's extraordinarily high
but it's an extraordinarily big case
it's an
extraordinarily uh serious case
with an extraordinary history
of this gentleman
of
fleeing
of hurting people
of not following court orders not
following
criminal laws
not following just
your societal norms
so i know that that's extraordinarily
high bail
it's
warranted here and i'm setting cash bail
in the amount of 5 million
a 5 million dollar bond is set for the
man officials say is behind the deadly
parade plow through in waukesha
wisconsin this as a death toll climbs to
six people the latest victim an
eight-year-old boy
thirty-nine-year-old daryl brooks
appeared in waukesha county court on
tuesday investigators say he
intentionally drove his suv through a
holiday parade route in on sunday
killing six people and injuring more
than 60 others on tuesday the waukesha
district attorney called for the 5
million bail saying brooks is a flight
risk and has a lengthy rap sheet that
spans across multiple states at the time
of the attack brooks was running from a
domestic disturbance incident the deadly
parade crash was just five days after he
was released from jail on a thousand
dollar bought bail in that case he faced
charges for running over his
ex-girlfriend in a gas station parking
lot officials say it was the same suv he
later rammed into the annual holiday
parade
right now he's charged with five counts
of first degree intentional homicide at
tuesday's hearing prosecutors made it
clear a six count will soon be coming
mr brooks is facing five consecutive
life sentences if he's convicted on all
counts in this complaint
i wish to notify the court sadly that
today we learned of another death of a
child
related to this case
we do expect a six count for first
degree intentional homicide to be issued
or added excuse me
to this case
i can advise the court that i am aware
i've been made aware through
investigators that there are other
individuals
in critical condition i think we remark
on the number of actual injured parties
in our complaint it exceeds 60 people
there's a number of
other charges that we are reviewing and
considering but certainly at the very
least we do intend to file a six count
of intentional homicide there are not
words to describe the risk that this
defendant presents to our community not
only flight risk but the dangerousness
that he presents his history of violence
and the allegations in this complaint
where
it is stated plainly that on several
occasions
he was told to stop by police officers
they risked their own safety to try and
step in front of the car to stop him
everything was done to get him to stop
and he just simply continued down the
roadway causing death and destruction in
his path
the court commissioner approved the
district attorney's request for a five
million dollar bail saying in a nearly
40 year long career he has never seen a
case of this magnitude
the nature of this offense is shocking
uh actually the detail i was not
expecting here today
that two two detectives
not laypeople detectives
not only tried to stop this
but rendered an opinion that this was an
intentional act
you're presumed innocent sir but that's
what the allegations are
and i not seen anything
like this in my
very long career
it seems to be a very strong case for
the state
likelihood of incarceration which is the
other aspect of veil
is absolute if you are found guilty of
any one of these a multitude of them
it's a life imprisonment
sentence that must be needed out
let's bring back former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and terry austin
to discuss terry as the death toll rises
in brook's newest case do you think the
prosecution will try to cut a plea deal
with him or throw the buck at him i
think the prosecution is going to throw
the book at him and they're going to
have these five charges and maybe now
six charges because we know for a fact
that one child has now died so the loss
of life was magnificent and the fact
that it was so intentional and the fact
that he has so many
criminal acts behind him they're violent
acts he is a flight risk i don't think
the prosecution is going to go lightly
and unless there's some mental illness i
think he will probably be convicted
because it's right out there in the open
yeah there's
plenty of eyewitnesses there's
definitely going to be some more video
that comes in it's a parade people are
out there taking cameras and pictures
and video so see how that continues gene
as a former prosecutor where do you put
the blame when you look at brooks's
record and how we got to the death of
now six people
here's where i put the blame on november
5th
he was charged with uh running over his
trying to run over his girlfriend
obviously had a bond hearing i put the
blame on the prosecutor at that bond
hearing i put the blame on the judge who
released him
i i put the blame on several people
maybe the pre-trial officer
how this man was released
with that criminal record uh after
november 5th is beyond me and look what
happened yeah i i would tend to agree
there as well we know that his right to
a speedy trial enacted and they couldn't
get that uh process up and going and so
his bails reduce uh down to 500 and a
thousand dollars depending on the case
you're looking at and that when you look
at the seriousness and the violence of
the case is something that even myself
as a public defender here in brooklyn i
don't see uh in any of my cases so i i
tend to agree with you there gene uh
thank you for that input both of you
coming up on law and crime daily a hefty
settlement reached in the so-called
unite the rights lawsuit out of
charlottesville virginia
plus a more than 40-page investigation
released in the alleged sexual
misconduct by former new york governor
andrew cuomo what the report says after
this
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
after an eight-month long investigation
officials say there's overwhelming
evidence that former new york governor
andrew cuomo engaged in sexual
harassment while in office
nearly 50 pages of investigation records
were released this week showing cuomo
engage in multiple instances of sexual
harassment and other kinds of misconduct
the investigation found cuomo created a
hostile work environment by engaging in
sexual misconduct with multiple people
it also says cuomo used state resources
to write publish and promote his book
wrin on his response to the covet 19
pandemic and that his office made
changes to a department of health report
to protect his reputation amidst the
pandemic this latest report corroborates
an earlier investigation put on by new
york attorney general leticia james that
was released in august
that same month cuomo resigned from
office amidst the sexual harassment
scandal and an impeachment threat just
last month charges were filed against
cuomo in albany county for groping a
former staff member
back to break down this report on former
governor andrew cuomo is former federal
prosecutor gene rossi and co-host terry
austin terry the report outlines the
environment created by cuomo in his
office and corroborates the sexual
harassment how does this affect his
albany county case and could we see more
women coming forward no question about
it this report is definitely going to
have an adverse effect on the criminal
case now we have two reports the first
as you mentioned by leticia james and
now by the state assembly saying
basically that he created a hostile work
environment that he definitely
participated in sexual harassment as far
as multiple women are concerned so i
believe that we're going to see that
information down the line in the
criminal investigation and the criminal
case so these aren't going to help him
one bit
now gene this report goes beyond sexual
allegations do you see any other
potential criminal charges whether they
be state or federal for cuomo
well in the light most unfavorable to
governor cuomo he could be facing a
ricoh charge
because the office of the governor could
be the enterprise and you could have at
least two predicate acts it could be
mail fraud wire fraud now if he's using
campaign funds
to impermissibly
promote his book for personal use that
could be wire fraud mail fraud bank
fraud and you could use the enterprise
of the office of the governor uh to to
lay that charge on him that's the worst
he could face
well it's interesting because we saw
rico charges used in a similar fashion
with r kelly and the edny typically we
think of rico as like drug campaigns so
maybe we'll see
the former king of rmb getting convicted
of rico charges and now maybe the same
thing happens to the former governor of
new york as you've outlined there of
course we'll follow the case and we'll
follow the facts first and see if that
does in fact come up and we'll be sure
to report it here on law and crime daily
on update now on a story we first
brought you on long crime daily los
angeles county wants the lawsuit filed
by vanessa bryant thrown out the widow
of basketball legend kobe bryant filed a
lawsuit against the county last year
claiming severe emotional distress and
invasion of privacy after photos of the
crash taken by los angeles county
workers were leaked in january 2020 kobe
bryant his 13 year old daughter gianna
and seven other people died in the
helicopter crash on monday la county
asked that the lawsuit be dismissed
saying that because the photos weren't
shared to the general public vanessa
bryan's harm would be quote hypothetical
they also allege brian has never seen
the photos this comes after a judge
ordered brian to turn over her mental
health records dating back to 2017 as
part of the lawsuit brian has until
november 29th to hand in those records
when we come back a victory for the
victims of the 2017 charlottesville
rally
how much the organizers are ordered to
pay out and what charges they were found
liable for all that and more after the
break
[Music]
and a monumental victory in the
so-called unite the rights lawsuit as
rally organizers are found liable in the
deadly charlottesville riots this as
their order to pay more than 25 million
dollars to those affected by the fallout
the jury found all two dozen defendants
liable for conspiracy and racial
religious or ethnic harassment this
stems from the so-called unite the right
rally in august of 2017 when white
supremacist groups gather to demonstrate
in charlottesville virginia the rally
was in response to the removal of
confederate symbols by local governments
that followed the charlottesville church
shooting in 2015. during the rally a
self-identified white supremacist rammed
his car into a crowd of counter
protesters one woman died and dozens
others were injured two virginia state
troopers also died in a helicopter crash
that was assisting with public safety
after nearly one month long federal
trial the jury determined rally
organizers were liable on a state
conspiracy claim they did not reach a
verdict on two federal conspiracy claims
but attorneys for the plaintiff say they
intend to get a verdict on those counts
in the future
gene what message do you think this
verdict sends to future political
assemblies that could turn violent
if you hate if you organize hate if you
encourage violence
uh forget the criminal laws you're
subject to those uh you could be sued
civilly and you'll have to pay you'll
get a judgment against you it's a great
day it's a great case and uh one of the
lead attorneys karen dunn i worked with
her when we were both in the u.s
attorney's office she's a brilliant
litigator i'm very happy and proud of
her
now this is one of the many shortcomings
i think of federal court i wish we had a
camera in there so we can see the
brilliance of this litigation and be
able to spell this out better for our
viewers but unfortunately the federal
government hasn't got to where many
states are in terms of transparency in
the court and terry that kind of leads
you to my next question i can already
imagine people claiming a double
standard between this charlottesville
and riots like what happened in kenosha
what do you think the difference is
between this case and other protests
that turn violent well i think the
difference here brian is the fact that
the organizers of this protest the white
nationalists actually were individuals
who were promoting this violence and
people ultimately died most protests you
have obviously a first amendment right
to speak but you don't have a right to
go in and have a violent response when
you are really trying to say some sort
of message clearly it's a message that
most people don't believe in but you
have a right to say that but you cannot
go out like gene said and promote that
sort of violence and hopefully it does
send a message to people out there that
you have to be responsible you have to
be organized but you have to make sure
that violence doesn't result as when you
are doing these types of protests so i
think it was a great decision well thank
you very much terry and thank you jean
as always and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you